everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we are in round
number 9 the final round of the 2017
grand prix in a Geneva and we have a
tree because the top two players in the
tournament are currently playing in the
last round why it's going to be played
by Yanukovych and a blacks going to play
my team or rather Bob and it doesn't
always happen like this
but in this tournament Alexander at
issue who is tied for second
he drew earlier so that means that one
of these players will be the champion
white does need a victory to be the
champion he is a half a point behind
Susan you need that full point to jump
team art but black only needs a draw so
you can kind of get a sense for what
both sides are going to be looking to do
in this game white starts out with pawn
to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and
then Bishop to c4 getting into the
Italian game for the quiet game and we
see a lot more of the right Lopez with
Bishop to b5 button is figure game a
bishop here to c4 Knight f6 pawn to d3
much more common to see pawn c3 getting
ready to push forward with pawn to d4 in
the center but kind of takes more of a
quieter approach this is the very quiet
game if you will Bishop to a c5 castle
on the kingside pawn d6 and then pawn c3
so why it's going to be looking to
developing pieces a little bit more and
then eventually at some point he will
want to be playing this pawn to d4 in
the center of the board pawn to a6 and
then pawn up here to a4 castle on the
Kings side for black pawn Age 3 just
stopping some of the squares that black
can come down to Knight g4 is now
blocked off Bishop to g4 pinning down
the knight to the Queen is blocked off
so black does the same thing pawn to h6
you can tell from blacks point of view
he's fine playing this when I would
consider a draw-game variation in the
Italian game so you're not going to see
him doing anything too crazy right now
he has a good position he's not under
any pressure right now he's just going
to see what his opponent does knowing
that if he gets a draw he is the
champion in the tournament one thing
that's important to note about these top
Ram masters is they know all the games
that have been played especially recent
games and tournaments they know all the
variations they have teams behind them
that are studying these they want to
know if another top player has found a
particular line then maybe is a novel
line that hasn't been played much they
want to see how different players are
thinking about it just last month we had
Magnus Carlsen Wesley so playing in
Norway for the big chess tournament
there and Magnus Carlsen we was playing
the white pieces Wesley so was playing
the black pieces and we saw Wesley so
played Bishop to e6 and then after the
exchange we see pawn takes on e6 a
little bit interesting from Wesley so
that he would immediately go ahead and
open up this F file and have double
pawns in the center now double pawns in
the center not as bad if you have a pawn
next to it here on the D file a lot of
ways for you to get rid of that double
pawn and it really allows you to control
much of the center of the board and
always be controlling the dark squares
but this pawn here on e6 is also
controlling these light squares as well
but play continued pawn appear to be
four so Magnus Carlsen tried to push in
to his advantage on the Queen side
bishop back here a7 we did see in
exchange now White has a double pawn on
the e-file 97 Knight B to d2 Knight d6
pawn push forwards a little bit but this
game ended in a draw now from blacks
perspective you could look at this and
say okay drawl is great because that
would give me the victory in the
championship but if you kind of look at
it it's not an easy game to play so
while I'm pretty confident that the team
art was prepared for this if you wanted
to go down this this line I do think the
pond h6 is much safer and he doesn't
have to worry about any of the
complications that could have come that
from the game that he saw from Magnus
Carlsen and Wesley so work over here to
e one this does a couple things one it
does protect a pawn on e4 but also
allows them if he wants to bring his
Bishop to e3 not have to worry about
recapturing with this pawn you can now
recapture with
rook you'd like to now black decided to
go and bring his bishop to a 7/9 d2
night back here to e7 and this kind of
signals that it's go-time
white needs to do a couple thing he
needs more defenders or attackers on the
d4 square or he needs his opponent to
retreat some of his attackers or
defenders on the d4 square that's
exactly what white sees right now the
nights here on c6 was defending the
square here on d4 and so after the Night
Moves then we kind of go time for white
here so pawn pushing for 2d for trying
to take control of the center of the
board blacks completely okay with that
just brings it that over here to g6 says
yeah go ahead and do your thing that's
fine if you want to a bishop down here
f1 this is kind of one of those
interesting moves of you have a very
strong attack in the center of the board
bishop coming back here to f1 just seems
counterintuitive there's so many other
ways that white could continue here
Queen to b3 developing the Queen really
eyeing and this long white diagonal that
seems really good could also just play
Queen to see to get involved into the
action protecting the square here on e4
so doesn't have to worry about his rook
or his knife as well could play Knight
to b3 just get it out of the way so the
Queen is protecting the square here on
d4 also just want to open up the door
for the darks for a bishop you get
involved at some point in the game or
you can just play pawn to b4 just say if
you want to bring your knight over here
that's fine I'm going to go and take
this opportunity to start pushing on the
Queen side all of those I think are much
more aggressive place from whiteness and
if you're playing for the win which
white really needs to be playing for the
win a draw does him no good unless you
just wants to get second place but I
think you should be playing for the win
here with the white pieces so all in all
Bishop to f1 is a fine move I just think
there were other options that gave him
more opportunity to press his advantage
as white rook to e8 just protecting the
center of the board now Queen to c2 nice
back here to h7 so applying somewhat
defensive night 287 trying to bring it
to another square a night here to g4
could bring it back here to f6 if you
wants to but not really doing too much
with that night here on h7 right now
pawn takes on e5 recaptures and that
appear to c4 attacking the pawn queen
down here eventually wants to get that
involved so decide to go and bring it
here to f6 attacking both the night
putting more pressure on the pawn right
here on g2 protecting that also
defending the square here on e5 nice it
to e3 and then I'd up here to e7 Knight
to g4 attacking the pawn and the Queen
and we just see in exchange right here
so Bishop takes on g4 the pawn
recaptures Knight here to g6 Bishop here
to see for this is kind of nice because
it allows you know black if he wants to
to bring his knight down here to f4
that's going to be a great little
outpost first decides to go and bring
his rook to the ace you really want to
have your major pieces controlling the
center of the board and that's exactly
what he does here rook here to DA has
both of his rooks in the center black
has a pretty good position he's going to
need to get his nice involved into the
action White has double bishops so he
needs to really open up the center of
the board control the game with those
bishops this starts for a bishop over
here white definitely has to be aware of
that it does control this entire dark
square diagonal from a7 all the way down
to the King here so that is going to be
putting pressure on white pawn pushing
forward to a5 you know I'm not sure it's
doing too much but decides to go and
push his advantage on the Queen side the
board night down here to f4 as we talked
about and then Knight coming to h2 seems
a little bit odd to bring your knight
back to h2 it does protect the pawn on
g4 but it's not like he's maneuvering
the knight to h2 to go somewhere else
there's no other squares you can go to
unless you want to come back to the
first rank which seems kind of bad and
then pushing forward to e3 so this seems
a little defensive in my opinion for
white the white pawns not really under
any pressure right now
so I don't think he has to do this he
had some other options you can now play
Bishop to e3 and then if there is an
exchange on board you could take with
your pawn although it's double pawned it
forces the knight to move and I think
that's going to be fine on board but in
the game decide to go and play Knight to
H 2 2 more continues rook d7 getting
ready to bring his other work over here
to d8 with the double rooks control the
only open file in the game Bishop to e3
so we eventually see this and then the
pawn takes much rather take with your
rook because you don't want to have
double pawns in the center of the board
especially if you don't have pawns on
either side of it but this night here on
f4 just has to go it's such a very
powerful outpost that decides to go
ahead and take with his pawn to force
the knight back so Knight comes back
here to e6 and then Brooke to f1 trying
to control the semi open file forcing
the Queen to move Queen up Queen back
here to e7 pawn pushes forward to b4
just solidify the pawn chain making sure
the Queen can't come by as well Knight
to g5 you know I really like nice to f6
it attacks both of these pawns here on
g4 in e4 ties down the Queen's to pawn
and the knight to the pond I think this
was more aggressive and I recognize that
black doesn't have to be too aggressive
but I just think it's Hall better move
than Knight here to g5 but this is why
he decides to play now Knight to f3
if black wants to exchange and he
decides to go ahead and do that pawn
recaptures on f3 so both sides trading
down which I think bodes well for black
equal and material here so I think it's
a little bit easy for him to draw in the
game Queen down here to g5 just
attacking the backward bishop here or
pawn on e3 rook to e1 protecting the
pawn rook here to d8 doubled up on the D
file Queen over here h2 and then a rook
to d2 you always want to get your rooks
both doubled up and then also on your
opponent's second rank if you're black
for white you want to get up here on the
seventh rank you can get behind enemy
lines start to kick off some of your
opponent's pawns also just limits sum of
the squares your opponent can go to
specifically his
King rook here to e2 could see an
exchange on board decides first to come
down to d2 so if there's an exchange he
can come down with some tempo first we
see Bishop to a d5 trying to block off
these rooks connected and then there's
an exchange on board pawn to c6 forcing
the bishop to move we see in exchange
but first rook down here do you one sec
King 2f tube and then the exchange choke
now black and white both have the double
pawn structure on the e-file you know
black is fine here he has some very
active pieces he just doesn't have a lot
of them so right now it's just a matter
of getting into the in game see if any
side can really get behind enemy lines
and make something of it right now I
would say if anyone it's black because
White's playing pretty defensive right
now and then white plays what I thought
was a kind of a white flag of alright
I'm not even going to try for the win
let's just go and exchange Queens off
the board like didn't take too long to
go ahead and just take on h5 as you
could probably imagine this makes it
much easier for him to draw the game so
we see the Queen come off the board King
here to f7 starting to activate the King
King now is a very valuable piece
getting into the in-game work here to be
to rook see one rookie to controlling
the open file King e7 now the route
can't really do too much he'd like to
come here to D set and that would be the
dream square you can get behind enemy
lines King to e7 is going to stop that
rook to d3
we're could be here h1 attacking the
pawn is going to end up losing that pawn
to black goes up material pawn c4 we see
some checks back and forth getting some
time back on the clock once you get to a
certain move and so that's kind of what
we see here and then rook to g5 King
over here to h2 pawn age 4 so just
pushing on the King side while white
pushes on the Queen side pawn h4 King up
here to h3 and then work down here to g3
is pretty interesting decides to go and
give up its past pawn on the each file
for the pawn here on
the F file and that's fine still has a
passed pawn on g7 that he can push if he
wants to or you know all in all he could
just easily get to the in-game and have
a drawled game so pawn takes on a six
pawn recaptures pawn up here to c5 rook
down here f1 rook to d6 it's an outpost
but it's not doing too much fruit come
here to a-1 says if you want to go and
take my pawn that's fine I'll take yours
as well
and that's what they decide to do King
to g5 but with the rook over on the a
file this pawn is not really going to be
able to hold on for very long King to d7
forcing the rook to move rook here to d6
it's an outpost check and then we see
some some back and forth from both sides
at the end of day there is a tuple
repetition both sides say let's go ahead
and draw this thing neither sides
probably going to win here so
congratulations to team R he is your
champion after tying the last game he
played a phenomenal tournament and then
yonder pone Mitch you know he got 2nd he
tied with Alexander district so
congratulations to him a team are still
in the running for being one of the top
two in the Grand Prix had a strong
finish in the last tournaments for in
the Grand Prix ended up winning this one
so if he can get first potentially
second depending on where everything is
sorted out he will be one of the top two
so congratulations to him on a victory I
would have liked to see maybe white push
a little bit harder with the variation
that's more complicated or try in this
positions specifically to try something
to put black to the test I think all in
all black had a pretty easy game to get
to a draw state but great tournament
really enjoyed the coverage so thank you
all for watching and following along and
I will see you in the next tournament
thanks everyone